les vélos ont été rangés remplacé par
les platines de dimanche à lundi le
vélodrome nationale a vécu 14 heures de
concert cinq artistes et groupes se sont
succédé trois heures de 7 pour un état
dj membres du blockhaus un collectif
promouvant la techno s'asseoir un peu
les gens vont voir dans les clubs déjà
et puis je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de
la techno d'être dans des lieux aussi
imposant emblématique pour paris
importante dans l'air centrale un public
venu de toute la france montigny le
bretonneux bien sûr mais aussi coup dans
caen lyon paris ou encore marseille ja
pour m'éclater avec mes potes taper un
peu du pied et s amuser comme on peut
pour faire la fête on a entendu il y
avait une soirée plutôt façon il y avait
des bons cette heure on est venu tout on
adore la techno tous du coup on est venu
pour vraiment s'éclater toute la soirée
je voulais faire l'art en série ted
haggard saint lazare j'ai
malheureusement pas pu la terre et j'ai
eu des retours de monstrueux qui était
difficile et là j'ai vu là hors série je
me suis dit qu'il fallait absolument que
je fasse
succès donc pour ce deuxième rendez vous
hors série après la gare saint lazare en
septembre dernier près de 4000 personnes
ont dansé jusqu'au petit matin
[Musique]